breaking news
und wir können in diesem moment
bestätigen dass die deutsche bundeswehr
mit allen gemeinsamen soldaten und allen
flugzeugen aus kabul gestartet ist also
dieses gelände was in den vergangenen
minuten angegriffen wurde verlassen hat
und alle soldaten alle deutschen
soldaten aus kabul man muss es so sagen
raus bekommen hat also drei maschinen
die kurze vor vor diesem anschlag dort
über hast überhaupt erst aufgesetzt sind
haben in extrem hoher geschwindigkeit
dann offenbar umgedreht und haben jetzt
kabul verlassen sind auf dem weg nach
taschkent usbekistan und offenbar hat
damit dann auch der deutsche abzug aus
afghanistan noch mal beschleunigt noch
mal schneller stattgefunden eigentlich
war der plan erst gegen 19 uhr das land
zu verlassen noch mal so viele menschen
mitzunehmen wie es geht aber da haben
nun die militärischen planer offenbar
anders entschieden unsere kollegin
angelika hellemann die hat diese
information in diesen minuten erhalten
und wir können sich hier bestätigt
vermelden